Speaker 1: Continuing our COVID quack cures,
treatments and whatever part of the show,
I'm going to play a clip for you. Unfortunately,
if someone that was taken kind of seriously by
some early in the pandemic, there is a. This is
a so-called vaccine expert named Stella Emanuel.
And early in the pandemic, there were a bunch of
people taking her very seriously. She appeared
on The Stu Peters show. This is the guy who
thought when he had a cold not long ago that
someone weaponized the cold and gave it to him,
he probably just had COVID. He's unvaccinated.
He brought on Stella Emmanuel to defend
his Satanic Snake Venom documentary,
and she says that the world is filled
with demonic clones. This is someone
that the right was going to as an authority on
COVID earlier in the pandemic. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: I saw people walking on the street
and some ways you went on, some other demons
and human beings. You realize that we're
walking around with demons. So right now,
we are in a time where I would actually say people
have been cloned and they are walking among us.
If you watch the movie call the leave they like is
that it was created by John Carpenter. This is the
world we live in right now, and the only way we're
going to survive. If human beings wake up, stop
all the crazy factions. The devil has put us in
a stop crying and crying out to God. God, that is
the only way we're going to. We're going to stop
Speaker 1: now, often with these folks. I
come to you and I say, this is not a
medical doctor. The crazy thing is,
Stella Emmanuel is a medical doctor. She is as
far as I know she is a physician and a pastor,
and she was pushing hydroxychloroquine, absent
any evidence. She said social distancing and
masks don't work and all of this different
stuff. Now, as a reminder about Stu Peters,
he is this radical right wing broadcaster.
He had the cold or flu or COVID, and he said,
I'm not going to get tested, but I believe that
I was targeted with this. Someone injected me
with it. This is a very, very dangerous
guy. Here's another clip where Stu Peters
speaks to a guy named Brian Artists, and they
claim COVID is a synthesized form of snake venom.
That's the snake venom connection. Well, what
Speaker 6: about the name corona, right? Have
a Latin definition or definition. It also asks,
So what's the definition? And on Dictionary.com,
it brings up 13 definitions. Corona religiously
ecclesiastical means gold ribbon at the base
of a miter. Oh, I don't know what a miter was,
so I copied and pasted it and then hit images.
So this actually could read the pope's
venom pandemic, whoa. It also can read
Crown Corona means crown also in
Latin terms. Corona means crown.
Visually, we see kings represented
with a crown symbol. Oh man. So put
that together for me. King cobra
Speaker 1: venom. It actually eyes
the virus is the venom of a king.
Speaker 6: Cobra could read
King Cobra Venom pandemic.
Speaker 1: Now, just as a reminder,
Artis is a chiropractor. He's not an infectious
disease doctor. He's not a medical doctor.
He's not a virologist. He's a chiropractor. And
he believes he has figured it out. These people
are dangerous, and unfortunately, they have
followers. Very, very sad stuff. Tragic, really